Un domeniu în care calculul cuantic ar putea îmbunătăți machine learning
este legat de funcțiile nucleu sau
matricele nucleu — hai să vedem ce sunt acestea
și de ce avem nevoie de ele; pentru asta ne vom reaminti
trei lucruri: de ce apar produsele scalare în machine learning,
de ce problemele de machine learning implică dimensiuni mai mari
și ce sunt funcțiile nucleu
reamintește-ți că produsul scalar sau produsul interior al
unor vectori reali n-dimensionali a
și b este dat de produsul magnitudinii lui a,
al magnitudinii lui b și cosinusul unghiului theta dintre ei
— acest lucru e echivalent cu înmulțirea
fiecărei componente din a cu componenta corespunzătoare din
b și adunarea lor; de reținut că dacă vectorii sunt
aproape ortogonali, de exemplu când a
are componente nule acolo unde b are componente mari,
produsul scalar este mic — asta e echivalent cu
theta apropiindu-se de pi pe doi
similar, dacă a are componente negative iar b
are componente pozitive,
adică vectorii indică în
direcții aproape opuse
și theta e aproape de pi,
rezultatul produsului scalar poate fi
negativ; în fine, dacă a are componente mari acolo unde b
are și el componente mari de același semn,
adică vectorii sunt aproape paraleli și theta e în jur de zero,
produsul scalar va fi mare
și pozitiv — deci e foarte rezonabil să ne așteptăm ca produsele scalare
să fie o măsură utilă a similarității
dintre punctele de date; nu orice dată n-dimensională
poate fi separată ușor într-un spațiu n minus
unu dimensional, adică printr-o linie,
un plan sau un hiperplan; când datele nu sunt bine separate
în n dimensiuni, putem să le încorporăm
în dimensiuni mai mari, să zicem m dimensiuni, unde m
este mai mare decât n — asta se numește feature mapping
notat adesea ca x ducând la phi(x), unde
phi(x) este o mapare din numerele reale n-dimensionale în
numerele reale m-dimensionale
e mai ușor de vizualizat când
ridici un set de date unidimensionale în
două dimensiuni sau când iei date bidimensionale
și le încorporezi în trei dimensiuni
dar în realitate încorporăm adesea date în spații cu mii
sau chiar milioane de dimensiuni
un produs scalar al unor vectori tridimensionali față de un produs
scalar al unor vectori bidimensionali e o diferență nesemnificativă
dar un produs scalar al unor vectori cu un milion de dimensiuni
devine complet intractabil
pentru a-l aplica unui set de date mare
deci oamenii au găsit un truc ingenios:
ce-ar fi să folosești o proiecție
în dimensiuni mai mari care are o formă foarte specifică
astfel încât produsele scalare ale vectorilor în
dimensiuni mai mari să fie o funcție simplă a
vectorilor din dimensiunile inferioare — adică găsim o mapare
de la datele noastre x la un phi(x) de dimensiune mai mare
astfel încât produsul interior în
spațiul de feature-uri să fie dat de o
funcție simplă în datele de dimensiune inferioară.
Această funcție k se numește funcție nucleu
ideal am vrea ca această funcție nucleu
să fie o funcție a
produsului interior de dimensiune inferioară în sine — asta ne-ar da
ce e mai bun din ambele lumi: un spațiu de feature-uri de dimensiune foarte mare
dar cu un produs interior ieftin și ușor de calculat
la prima vedere poate că nu e
evident că asta e posibil — hai să ne uităm la
un exemplu simplu în dimensiuni foarte mici
consideră această mapare de feature-uri specifică: mapează un
vector tridimensional într-un
spațiu de nouă dimensiuni — se dovedește
că produsul interior al spațiului de feature-uri de nouă dimensiuni mapat
este pur și simplu dat de produsul interior în spațiul
3D original la pătrat — deci produsul interior
al spațiului mapat folosind funcțiile phi
ar necesita calculul fiecăreia dintre cele
nouă coordonate pentru
primul vector și nouă pentru
al doilea, apoi produsul interior în sine, care este
alte nouă produse și o sumă —
un total de douăzeci și opt de operații
funcția nucleu necesită trei produse
și două sume, adică doar patru operații
asta a fost pentru maparea unui punct de date tridimensional în
un spațiu de feature-uri de nouă dimensiuni
e ușor de văzut că asta poate fi extrem de avantajos
pentru spații foarte mari.
Funcția nucleu este în mod tipic o funcție continuă
pe care o poți aplica oricărui vector din setul tău de date
dar folosim funcțiile nucleu luând
perechi de puncte de date din setul nostru
ca argumente; aplicarea unei funcții nucleu la
fiecare pereche de puncte de date din set
rezultă într-o matrice simetrică numită matricea
nucleu; tipul de funcție nucleu pe care îl vei folosi depinde de
problema ta — deci, ca recapitulare:
descrierea similarității vectorilor din seturile noastre de date
necesită adesea produse interioare; produsele interioare în
spații de feature-uri de dimensiune foarte mare devin costisitoare
deci folosim mapări de feature-uri corespunzătoare
anumitor funcții nucleu speciale
care fac calculul mai eficient
dar această restricție la funcții nucleu speciale
limitează ce tipuri de mapări în spațiul de feature-uri pot
fi făcute eficient — asta
ne poate împiedica să separăm bine datele
dacă numai ar exista o altă cale...
aici intră în scenă calculul cuantic
maparea de feature-uri în dimensiuni foarte mari corespunzătoare
funcțiilor nucleu poate fi realizată
pe un calculator cuantic în estimatorul de nucleu cuantic
matricea nucleu k este calculată
iar de acolo un algoritm clasic de machine learning poate fi
folosit pentru a realiza asta — un punct de date x unu
este încărcat și mapat, apoi
un alt x doi este încărcat
și mapat; deoarece produsul interior a două stări cuantice
este legat de probabilitatea de măsurare,
putem estima produsul interior al celor două puncte de date mapate
făcând suficient de multe măsurători ale
circuit-ului rezultat — în acest fel, circuit-ul nostru
ne poate spune despre un produs interior
în orice spațiu de dimensiune mare pe care circuit-ul îl poate modela
fără să calculăm vreodată clasic un produs interior sau o
funcție nucleu; există multe modalități de
a personaliza și îmbunătăți aceste metode
și într-adevăr sunt mereu propuse metode noi
și testate — sperăm că această
prezentare generală v-a fost de ajutor în înțelegerea
aplicării calculului cuantic
în metodele de machine learning
în special a celor care implică nuclee